hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast applying mid-iron microbial
genomics and complex metagenomics and
Brenda Kelly chem lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by Oxford nanopore
technologies Oxford nanopore developing
and commercializing a new generation of
nanopore based electronic systems for
analysis of single molecules including
DNA RNA and proteins the handheld men
iron device is designed to provide
simplicity of workflows and real-time
data stream for more information please
visit www an apport XCOM we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit your questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation Linda
will try to get to as many questions as
time allows you can enlarge the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem for the green Q&A button lower
left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Daniel tourney dr.
Turner is the applications director at
Oxford nanopore technologies where he is
responsible for developing library
preparation methods to allow men iron
users to work with a broad range of
sample types and working with external
collaborators to demonstrate new uses
for the technology I'll now hand it over
to dr. Turner for his presentation great
well thanks very much brighter for
introduction and so in thanks everybody
for tuning in his room and us Brenda
said my name's Dennis owner and senior
director of applications or to multiple
technologies
I'm assuming that some people watching
this presentation remember fair amount
about it available among the technology
but also that some people working with
ink so I'm going to spend the first few
minutes talking about what technology is
and how it works okay this slide
illustrates optimum position for a
complete end-to-end solution from sample
to analyze results so not just a company
who makes the sequencer we want to
provide the whole end-to-end process
from the Sun whether that's blood leaf
cell culture or whatever through to
sample extraction writing preparation
sequencing to flow analysis of the
results so we're telling the biological
information that the experimental set
out to investigate repair on the right
shows up kimiko which is a scalable
high-throughput standalone device that's
going to be available towards the able
to hear but for this presentation I'm
going to be focusing am in aisle which
is a monthly portable device this
usually the same sensing chemistry
supreme ether so everything that's
possible in a minute will not be
possible on premier I'm like this is
available so the concept of using
animals to sequence DNA has been around
for a couple decades and it's Emma
straited here and a sketch from David
dealers notebook in essence you have a
nanopore sitting in a nunnery of some
sort and you have an Arabic buffer
Tyneside when an electrical potential is
applied a current flows so Islands move
from one side of the membrane together
and as an intact DNA strand passes
through report the current changes this
is more or less how you do today is I'm
explain shortly they look simple but the
challenge is making it robust scalable
and high throughput has been a lot of
academic research into various eaters
and nine Paul's a census over the last
20 years Tristan's detecting small
molecules such as TNC or using them to
c-bus proteins it's this versatility
that lies behind rocks and on false
prophets to be described as making
sensing devices rather than just making
DNA sequences this is an honor for after
all that within the tiny country and as
long as you can get the molecule with
interest to interact with important
characteristic way and it's possible to
normalize it however for this
presentation on the focusing on the use
of an applause to sequence DNA and RNA
okay so how does it work the man come
across the use of solid-state menopause
in various contexts and then we have
strong interest here the mighty device
can be used as protein manacles this has
some distinct advantages first namely
that in a batch of protein levels or in
a more or less identical so we behave in
the same way and we can modify them
using conventional molecular biological
techniques to these particular
properties a magnum opus is a membrane
not Olympic membrane because that isn't
robust enough but we'd a synthetic
polymer which has got very high vertical
resistance when assaulting another
solution to both sided member may play
an electrical potential the current can
an exploding report and we measured
changes in current is analyzed path
report so the picture now shows the open
conference went in ugly blocking for
small molecules is the figure
illustrates choke off the current to
some degree enlarge another Kings
checked off the current season one this
isn't quite how things work on this don
t look at DNA but it does ever
straighten general principle when we
come to look at DNA the bases are
joining together and in the method which
we call strata sequencing DNA molecules
pass through the poor like this intact
when the danger passes through the
nervous personal call it chokes off the
code several places can fit into the
manager to the point any one instant so
I'm actually measuring come from a short
word rather than clean individual base
if five bases fit into the nanoparticle
all that we reading fun basis and we
have four to the power of five different
conventions because of the four
different types of base so that's the
thousand twenty thousand 24 which means
that we have to fit a thousand twenty
four different current levels is the
detection rate but because we make the
DNA move through the pond one day at a
time every time you need for noticing
the narrow visible posting the same for
one row to the next this means that when
you take the next currently writing
these four possibilities for me i
destined only word well that's near that
new base open course of the entire sky
Magellan's the season Carlile's each of
which is related to the previous one by
four of the five bases and use a hidden
markov
to convert their signal postcodes okay
so there are three essential components
in Apple sequencing there's what we call
the motor protein there's the man upon
itself and there's a member in richland
on applets we have a variety of
different menopause which we commute and
each interaction and sequencing template
know he was in slightly different way
making the electrical currents are
different and we can use this property
to our advantage dimensions only we need
a mini the membrane in high electrical
resistance so the clerk can only flow
the report not across the membrane lipid
bilayer by those are not very robust and
over only did use in the one stage we
notice the Kazakh problems is even we're
busted blood and finally we have the
notability in previous trading top
developer the needs of all the DNA to
look for one based at sign up one base
at a time so that we can work out what
the sequences so we only way of doing
them if we just like DNA or RNA things
will report I hated it goes through some
something like a million bases a second
that's a lot faster than the frequency
which we measure the code so we need to
slow it down the dealership by using
enzyme in which we call a rose
appointing the motor protein actually
said a few functions it slows down the
later books the DNA or RNA passes
through the port it acts as a ratchet
meaning that it needs one base at a time
pausing briefly each tiny boobs which
allows us to measure the current let's
also able to unwind the duplexer headed
so Rob will be needing to make our
citizen template single-stranded looking
use double standard template it's metal
loading preparation a lot easier as
we'll see in the next slide my
preparations the process accrue blessing
extracted genomic DNA or RNA or
afrikaans until format that's compatible
in the sequencing system this is showing
hands of genomic DNA Oxford and applause
current in any degree lambda crap is
quick and straightforward to perform
it's capable of generating very long
fragments of DNA which would give long
reads the user can share in the DNA to
start if they like it's not a
prerequisite and it's clearly not what
you'd want to do that you wanted very
long reads it does make sense of some
applications after shingling or not
sharing as the case may be the front
ends in repaired and the single ravenna
gems loop is added when adapters if i go
to them one of the adapters that uses
our happen
this connects both strands energy
plagiarism as a strategy sequence to
finalize reverse complement long as part
of the same sequence agreed this means
that we get two looks in each region of
DNA little artist a secret of greater
accuracy and the opposite end to their
happen we have a filter adapter and this
other adapter has various features which
increase the efficiency of the
sequencing reaction so it has a most
secondary structure in the strands are
more easily captured by the pool it has
a motor protein pre London ultimate
meaning but all my getting strands will
pass through the port at the right speed
and it has a reason to which we hundred
eyes and 10 ranked on beneath inside
which increases the sensitivity several
thousand fold this table on the gun has
a hydrophobic group of women which means
that the strategy able to associate with
a hydrophobic membrane better the
adapter also has a feature which stopped
the motor protein linking sway along the
strategy to expand is captured by the
pool so in solution motor proteins sits
on the strands not moving but as soon as
it captures countered by the portal that
allows it to stop excessive Armstrong
the library Pemex simmers in the other
next generation secretly might be
perhaps but there are a couple of
important differences firstly isn't any
creasing on all those possible to be a
piece are is part of a mighty process
Ferguson City don't have a lot of da to
begin with PTO introduces buyers then
reduce it the fragment length than it
has the redland and it's time to believe
in preparation process so if you kind of
want PCR is best to avoid it to the best
of my knowledge we have the only
sequencing technology that's capable of
sequencing the actual strand of DNA that
came from your visit of interest this
means that can get extremely the reeds
tens to hundreds of kilobases long so
far and we can detect modified basis
directly the second difference in the
mobile app and compared to conventional
next generation weather crops is we
don't routinely before size selection as
possible reason we don't need to do this
is because not approach randomly in
constantly samples transferred solution
so as soon as one strands passing the
pool another one gets captured and even
if there are shorter strands present and
along the alongside London is the
shortest going to take less time to pass
through it so you take it
proportionately less sequencing sign
that long strands not having
requirements of us what have you
informed the site selection means that
we avoid a laborious step all over it's
one that can be implemented
equipment editor Venus is large and
expensive that said if you want a lot of
leads that are an ugly kill based upon
warm Sun selection becomes more
important because DNA this site is
francha and so good preparations in this
I have to contain high proportions of
much smaller fragments of DNA as a slide
shows we also have a bark n ket
available to people here are for
instance looking at smaller templates
such as royalty phones or applicants and
they want to pull sequence and pull up
Roman sequence many of these together to
get better better family for the
sequencing hopefully it's clear clear
from before which one I find that the
motor protein is not attached to the
portal if it was attached to the pool
then if something happens the motor
proteins such as if denaturing and would
lose 94 so the motor is attached to the
template strands as a scan is captured
by the poet starting with the long
strands I'm wiping the helix ahead of it
the unwound strand is funking the poor
long days at a time and because I'm
happen most comes on the Jeep plants go
through data map data from both strands
is can branch on their internal analysis
into what we call a TD you need this has
got higher accuracy compared to ants
driving alone once the template is
finished translating the motor plating
diffuses away and the poorly free to
capture the next round we learnt
template into the furnace a little
concentration with sufficient and
minimize American port side between one
strand in the next is typically in a
fraction of a second so the pores are
occupying pretty much all at the time
the final mota mota mota protein is that
we can adjust the speed at which it
processes a lot in Temple extra by
increasing or decreasing with
concentration of cofactors this means
that we can make the system run a lot
faster we can generate more data in our
separating slow mode we press the setup
process with dnase about 30 bases per
second platform but in fast mode we can
get about 400 pulses per second or even
walk purple we talked a lot about DNA
this also worth mentioning that lamby
balls and capable of sequencing are you
Native this is a work in progress phones
because we've been focusing mostly on
TNN but we have been getting very good
results on file in RNA directive it's
typical in signaling to convert RNA to
CD and it's a complimentary dinner
before sequencing this is something that
we can do easily live alone but it might
not always be ideal because reverse
transcriptase is dell's always precise
to the end of transcript
typically a piercing on with cdna
migrants and that's got all the
disadvantages that pcr craigs have
discussed earlier but also junior
compression of see the conversion of
orient acedia information about
modifications for the RNA bases of loss
we can go by the sequencing I'm going
directly in settling rate unfortunately
only thing work we can now get adapter
straight onto the other instruments and
you can pass those typical we can
prepare the first strand cdna and it can
leak this to the RNA strand so that we
can sequence the RNA followed by the CD
or vice versa this gives us new cleanses
have seen what the paranoids thought
about 90 basis which provides us with
wrong information up modifications as
the danger of the bottom right shows we
see a change in current levels as a
muscle as a modified based passes
through the portal and it doesn't just
affect what kind of as your moment we're
looking at your word and my fan base
will appear in several diseases it
passes through so we get several looks
at it which means that we can be more
confidence about it here's a look at the
minim and as you can see it's small so
it's portable and this opens up the
possibility of using is outside of
laboratory environment we've already
mentioned it's capable of producing non
rings as far as we can tell the only
thing which are limits on these lengths
is the quality of the input DNA one
thing that I haven't killed so far as in
the inside nature of the data generation
strands pass through the one important
tax and the current models imagine if
this happens it means that the Scimitar
Stratton started to pass through a pro
the data ground becomes available for
analysis the other factor here is that
there's not a fix runtime at the moment
middle or anything for that matter and
together these are things which open
with a lot of possibilities essentially
being able to stop a sequencing run as
soon as you have enough game to try to
the question that you set out our answer
what a product that other way you can
leave the different winning until you
see the thing that you want to see also
it means that conform something akin to
sequence capture except that it's on the
device so you sequence the first week
basis of Australian it it's not fun
region or the organism of interest you
can reject that strand by reversing the
electrical potential on that individual
court the midline connects door knocks
on my USB and the USB connection
provides the powerful in Ireland it's
how the data gets transferred from the
device
the bottle black panel you can see the
midline in more detail this is actually
a more recent version of the device than
Veronica top right the main visible
difference is that the lids hinged
rather than separate what were the
sequencing reactions take place on the
flow salvage of a consumable this
contains the pawns in memory to ever
live without it underneath the flow so
we have a custom application specific
integrated circuit or asic this is what
current this is what controls be applied
potential is how the electrical currents
are measured the rest of the device
consists of various bits of electronics
and fans and a fan to keep going a cool
then the bottom right pane you can see a
closer view of the area of the flow so
rather pause and then later this chip
has about 500 single medicals so that
describe the hominoid on the net web
site of assistant it's also worth
mentioning briefly the metrical castle
this currently hosts a range of
provocations built by oxen gullible when
the ultimate aim of supporting the rain
a variety of applications of my third
parties essentially an absolute some of
which will work with the hall sequencing
data and some of which will be high
level apps now built to magigate
metadata at a time for instance or four
games diseases in the not-too-distant
future it may turn itself on suffice or
integrations with the Internet of Things
so having heard all about the technology
if you're interested in trying that
really won't return map which is an
annoying access program that means net
for literally in two thousand dollars
you getting men are innocent and a
supply of consumables and analysis
software which allows you to run your
own experiments there's a very strong
and supportive online community where
you are able to discuss ideas to get
tips and fan collaborators and you're
also able to buy float consumables to
our online shop for details about please
visit our website which is www.hyken.com
we also have a good look at this
conference of virtual with so please do
check that out as well ok so on to
someone like mobile application to the
technology the first application I'd
like to talk about is de novo assembly
of microbial genomes using short read
sequences to try and assembly that has
been right into taking the noggin
putting it to a shoulder then trying to
piece it back together again so good it
can be read this may be more easily
visualized as being like a jigsaw
alright made
relevant threaten copies and st. jaques
are only two uncut different none of the
pieces mixed together shortly term with
the equivalents having very very logical
pieces to find out mulleting pieces fit
together in quite a mess of searching it
makes you a computational challenge and
what is up to tend to be in perfect it's
particularly difficult and sending them
to contain repetitive regions for
example if your pieces on running ff7
reading I'm gonna say [ __ ] can basis
rather than 100 basis and the task
becomes a lot easier and you get the
ability to resolve a piece that inside a
few kilobases of map is the big leaf
nodes are tuned for example 50 kilobases
the job see it needs it we're not get to
the point where you can generate leads
of 500 kilobases but there's no reason
why that would not be possible from the
perspective it's really just the
integrity of the DNA so as mentioned
earlier the challenge becomes one is
trying to extract a nickname DNA strands
etcetera over the strands don't break
okay so we wanted to test our ability to
sell the genome using only malleable
reads we wanted to start up with
something small but something more
interesting than lambda phage so we got
some media vary from collaborator Shan
television abidjan and nor say the DNA
comes from quite an interesting source
they discovered a virus in Siberian
permafrost it have been there for more
than 30 Thunder net the virus is
anonymous by violence standards it's
about one and a half micrometers mark
and this virus infecting need looks
possible to resonate the virus in the
laboratory now as the author's
protecting the paper as permafrost
thawing out the ability of viruses to
come back to life after tens and
thousands of years could have seen quite
worrying ramifications but alot what
we'll be looking at we were just in
choice assembling to you which is a term
that was fairly 80 which we had to piece
the oven IV which was unfortunate
because it meant bias and shelter leads
but we didn't have access to mention you
know so we had no choice but with a bit
of help from Nick moment actually quite
a lot of help as you get it and time
they were able to assemble the genome
two seconds ago that's one fragment
cutting the whole genome as you can see
from the melon plots of the assembly
against the publish reference things
much oh well I don't have any in line
with metrics for this one but i don't
think that have been especially good
since this was done before making sure
some have finished their polishing to
Nana polish but this means is nicely to
the wax land so earlier this year a
matte matte paper came out in nature
methods by lik know and Nick moment just
quick and john simpson in which they
demonstrated that is possible using any
mid line reads to assemble bacterial
genomes with single can take the first
part of method works by taking down a
pool reads detecting overlaps between
them and then subjecting their blood
leads to one more answer error
correction and then using just the
information contained in roots
themselves and their external sources
after this that we collectively to them
assemble using the scenario assembler as
possible to stop the assembly at this
point and the office found that when
they did this we got something like 19
include former self identity keep adding
finish reference genome decatur
australia the color but there then
developed an additional step which
doesn't work in bay space but it uses a
process form of the electrical current
levels generated by the militant milling
device which we call swingers and this
increases the own entity to about 90
random half percent we were really
excited by this and we wanted to try it
out ourselves we've been able to ascend
on the data set released by the
influence of the paper but we wanted to
look at achievement when we could
produce the sequencing data for
ourselves so made a couple of libraries
from the econo strain SCS 110 which we
just happen to have in online is 80
degree freezer because we use that look
as competent cells one of the lines that
were meant as a standard library which
had been made by fragmenting genomic DNA
as described on the earlier side the
focal length distribution was sent in
europe at around six kilobases the other
line moves when preparing almost exactly
the same way except that limited the
fragmentation step so the likely
fragments represented the original
fundamental distribution much more
closely and the other difference was
that we took more Kaylena slightly not
to share it to enliven corporation so
another vortex encloses the regional
distribution of Miss writing center in
the round around 30 king basis but the
containing on fragments going to run
over 100 kilobases but members delayed
but we got from your library 192
kilobases alone the fact that we look at
both strands of the DNA duplex confuses
me to say but what I'm really saying is
that the sequence that strength of 394
kilobases when they combine the data
two strands into a single hundred ninety
TKS weed we wanted to see what the
effect of having these on one needs will
be on a set so we took enough of her six
cannot waste ends up to cover the SCS
110 gene over 240 film mean I'm not
through not another incorrect this time
because we haven't understood standards
in house but through a piece of software
called pbc Mar which also hannah
collects reads and freeze them into this
valley assembler we've got several
counties after assembly as you can see
in the memo class robeez the closely
related k12 strain as the reference then
fitly was about three permit many bases
and got around ninety percent identity
it's worth mentioning that the error
correction America seems it in a
slightly better job Annihilator than PVC
are when you didn't do a polishing step
here which explains one of the identity
is flowing down here little one swoop
republished assembly will then repeated
assembly before mixture of the six
Caliphate reads and some ultra mermaids
very roughly ten fund HSN 20-fold
current overall after putting these
through this inevitable you can see that
we get a single continent which will
write a bill how surprising but it's
nice to city then 50 things about 4.5
mega bases which is the entire genome
the percentage identity was very
slightly lower hasn't came the coverage
is low anyway enough about 70 for
millions the bottom line is that one
reads make de novo assembly easy next
I'd like to talk about a real-time
application for species identification
but we like to call what's in my parts
on a link for short as I mentioned
earlier as soon as I started dealing has
passed a report that can be based on but
many communal eyes the one point flow
species are going to find in classified
in real time the classification amazing
a data structure which maps all came as
a birth 24 present in the reference
database to modern the NCBI taxonomy
tree things of this pre-processing
Leary's can really quickly classify by
looking at kaylas rather than by
aligning them against the routine
reference when pieces Krakens and up on
Congress to calculate the least common
ancestor and to filter to determine most
likely placement in the taxonomy tree
now that is a tax on ID from which a
classification sports scores computer
behind the school
confident we can be the classification
is correct and then you get a blue color
of the taxonomy tree nucleonic adverse
conflict these are concept companies
threshold depending upon whether the
aims to achieve maximum specificity or
maximum sensitivity and this is my
vacation is available through electrical
so we recently expanded database in to
include viruses as well as bacteria and
we're currently expanding mr. include
hungry as well which has to put on your
database by buying a range of different
phone RNAs from commercial supplier
repairing Iblees sequencing room and
hitting the data through the workflow as
you can see we included pepper myosin
now as well and although penta viruses
of DNA virus so we'll be prepared in a
different way from RNA viruses is one of
our favorites so being cleaned it in the
mix as well to make a rather bizarre
mess engineering example we then run the
win the growth flow and we obtain textin
on extreme shown here on the left now if
you remember from the previous life the
color codes and hopefully remember that
balloon is high confidence in the arrows
loan companies so you can see from the
tree that the viruses were identified by
me with high confidence but as well as
running the library with we also have
barked out of these rivals so we can
look at how well remember we can't coast
funnier to the actual reader that we got
I mean does the workflow introduce
biotin anyway some bar chart once just
come up and shows that the two sets in
weeds two sets of data including very
closely indicating that the woodwork
trim is quantitative but we wanted to
look at that a bit more closely because
it's a potentially very important
feature so to do this we took a
selection about table demons which we
have a good quality reference to I need
prepare libraries when we pulled in the
arbitral relationships with any use
quantitative PCR to quantify the
relative abundance of each achievement
in the library pool with intention of
comparable previously on posters we will
process it helps completely keeping cell
tentative as possible because in keeping
all these items are measuring the number
of copies of the genome whereas with
whole genome sequencing the numbers
fabulous amuses proportional to the size
of the gene
as you'll see from the block the keepers
young counts agree weldable data
indicating that link including the
sequencing nor is not a part of the
process is this quantitative raffle must
has sensitive is worthless ie down to
what level can we detect viruses and
bacteria example now giving them the
workflow is quantitative it's a second
impression of how many read you get from
sequencing and this is just a matter of
how might you need the master general
data so if you're interested in
detecting very low abundant species
using the room workflow and it's just a
matter of leaving the sequencing run for
longer as I said only because of the
real-time nature of sequence in early
night you're not confined to a fix
runtime so if you need more days at
which isn't even running so to summarize
whipped a quantitative workflow for
real-time species identification all
right let's see how this works in a
real-life situation as I'll talk about
in a few slides time the limitation of
the link workflow is if the sequencing
species demands if I needs to be
available added in the database if we've
encountered a species that's not in the
database it will be able to place
further up the phone genetics truly it's
a position grows more confidence anyway
it'll be a bit more not later we wanted
to apply them to the sample though it
would recognize much different various
species and so we thought of looking at
Cardinal this is a good son this is a
good summer because drinking
unpasteurized Council for something
that's fire the pony it tastes amazing
but there's a downside to and that
downside is that the whole reason that
not gets pasteurizing the first place
which is that woman look is replete with
pathogenic backs in there at the table
to talk shows it's not uncommon to all
the people you can know from drinking in
the classroom but that's not really
surprising given that Casper and
summative of time developers dangling in
their own excrement the table below
lists a few other pathogens commonly
found in Putnam pasteurized milk and
with some really nasty things in there
such as in scarier ecoli unknown 157 or
so
so we wanted to get some all I can see
what was in it but just in case we've
got a sample of note that was
comparatively pathogen 33 we've also
been good to you get some mysterion DNA
into my passing for good measure now
because of the health risks involved in
drinking unpasteurized milk is not as
easy to compromise the average looking
Arnold seem likely to be in fact in New
York State when we did these experiments
unpasteurized milk ins is barely even
it's not legal to buy this reason but it
is available if you do that if you can
go out to the front but if you guys to
affirmative I ugh what exactly so then
if those people who will sell more than
or cut the back of a knife because of
this raw milk is required to see the
cognition with us from this model of
even single top left picture obviously
her identity is protected to start
getting into trouble in the north and
we've got a few different samples so we
got cows milk we got goat milking me not
sheep's milk just to increase our
chances of having something interesting
to detect we must be more examples at
room temperature for a couple of weeks
before extracting the DNA without
extracting DNA spiking mr. area into the
cow's milk at nearly step achieve it in
reaction will have the sheeps and goats
milk is in the world with neurotic
pathogen DNA now when we run the sheeps
and goats milk through in workflow we
identify the range of bacteria with
different levels accountants this is why
you expect from the only one on mutton
what's effectively and environmental
something if you look at the tree at the
top you can assume calls down to the
subspecies are but with different
degrees of confidence so for instance
and we're going to try and imitate this
because it's maybe a little bit
difficult with the size of the side of
the picture but we see australian cir
asean liquid fastens with very hung
presidents remember what believe is high
conference in yellen's mode which in the
case that we're seeing this exact
straining the work a little further down
we see hopefully I'm sent in here right
ones and we see three different
subspecies and lactococcus lactis or
we'll all of those continents but the
notice one level higher I mean latter
caucus latest species is a much higher
content and this indicates that we do
have liked accomplished artists in
sample
big surprise there but we just don't
have one of the three subspecies the
present in the database mrs. similar
story for the sheep milk as well as
showing the button button none of the
things that we found in lean up samples
will cost too much surprised there are
things that I think I'm economy growing
milk or their comment for environment
will remain under cow's milk we see a
similar story in many respects and that
a lot of the bacterial species present
in America ones that you predict selling
lots of campus and pseudomonas but
what's especially interesting who is
that a good number of the species that
we identify the ones that are known to
cause mastitis now the status in dairy
cows is particularly bad because it
leads to necrosis surveillance issues
showing the photograph the matter and we
got presumably came from several cat and
because of the way you got the sample we
can't exactly trace it back to specific
animals but what we do know is that must
itís effects up to about 50 Center dairy
cattle so it's pretty much a certainty
that this is a genuine detection of the
disease what we also see in the
animation on the right is being rodent
able to detect the spiked in this daily
dealing with very very high confidence
and the number of counseling mr. neeraj
was more that's exactly the same as the
amount will be added by bus as you would
expect report stated water okay so this
is an illustration of the sorts of
things to which a min on and the
associated workflow sleep apart Nick
highlights the nanyang applications I
mean you can see how useful this
workflow in combination with a portable
sequencer would be monitoring the health
and lumpy need area hospitals but their
remaining problem is that to get the DNA
extracted and prepared for sequencing on
the right you still have to take various
bits of lab equipment such as a
centrifuge onto the farm or wherever
you're working so to address this need
we're working on a device which we call
Broncos and this is essentially a
million size cycling library preparation
to us the device is going to be
compatible with the Lightning preps that
we have including exceeding a pcr-based
perhaps are on a all of them it's
entirely para value must be making the
whole process truly impossible also not
only will be cheating device someone
it's Kate
extracting within there or are they from
a range of centers as well as performing
loading preparation to users choice so
use it just has to learn a bit of sample
will conform then sit back in writing
the secretively I'll take care of itself
anyone gotten to speech and
identification when we were at first
thinking about Lee Watson upon workflow
we set out to test it on an
environmentally sample and because much
of this work was being done in a New
York man it made sense the charlie local
something we decided to get some water
from Hudson you wanted to see was it and
on the left you can see David done from
the mute from New York in collecting
sample on the New Jersey side of the
river rather than going for the actual
and also and in which we thought the
bacterial count Magdalene commit fin we
went for some of the sludge at the
bottom of the rhythm as you can see in
the infected us we use the soil of DNA
extraction kit to get the DNA DNA as
example I mean either through the ring
of workflow you can see from the lib
tree that a range of different bacterium
came up but with low confidence as
indicated by the yellow circles if you
look at a table of species that were
identified we can see that a good memory
of these are in fact not very very
likely to be present in the sample so
such as shinning armor and D cell phone
back here just got the species and
subspecies than the present in the
database but only something like ten
percenter believes not anything in the
database remaining ninety percent of
weeds can be classified this indicates
that there are a lot of species in the
sample but are not in database because
they've not yet been sequenced so what
can we do rather well we'd read a few
articles about a device called ownership
as the schedule initiate dealership
consists of a microscope sized array of
small nails something like 350 the idea
is that you dip it into the south of
interest it's such a dilution that you
get on average one batting you're so
pale and you can mobilize the cells in
the journal such as anchor a gross the
venn assembly able hits the Yankee
including the including permeable
membranes which are like nutrients to
diffuse in the nars but
keep the back cheering where they are
they done put the iron ship back has
been burning for me to take the sample
in the first place during this time of
acting may or may not adapt to life in a
gross and I can't be sure about that and
it didn't really worry too much about it
but I setting on the experiment as will
see the photographs are on the right
showing the ownership in action we chose
to use the stream in the back of water
grandpa building in Oxford with our
sample primarily because it sits at the
confluence of a little look look and the
affluence for the sewage treatment for
expectant Charlie place to work and but
we're also confident that we could find
some bactine room there it's also
interesting to look here because the
streams are pop inside for people to go
fishing it and wanted to know exactly
what they were eating in fact you can
probably see in the central picture on
the right somebody president alloys he's
just taking a break fruit from fishing
to watch this infernal and collecting
water from the river which is me so we
amassed the eye shape and load melting
point I grows and then dipped it at
least the water assembling device and we
paid back into the stream for two weeks
ones on holiday letting chipped in to
work after that i'm curling my chip
removed only cheese and slime and other
disgusting things using sterile cocktail
sticks i push the agarose plugs into
separate ones in a deep no plates which
was filled with low salt and we medium
except that the meeting would be made in
drizzle water still a little water
instead of distilled water just in case
the bacteria present had specific
nutritional requirements the plate was
then left at room temperature and
exposed to daylight for about three days
we hadn't taken too much care to make
sure that there was our samples dilute
enough to give one vaccine by well our
relationship so we included an extra
step in process which was after the
cultures and grown just keep the light
on joining our place also making river
water ashaming the top arrange better we
then pick single colonies and bruising
in the same way before as the photo of
glycerol stocks in the bottom right
shows we've got a razor back tuna
getting cultures in a variety of colors
from white to cream to rest a pharisee
yellow
when an extracted the DNA from the field
leading to the current 500 set and
secretly when the sequences are run
through the big workflow the results
with family inconclusive but I said only
if a bacterial subspecies is not in the
residence then cannot identify with any
degree of confidence which explains why
the tree level right show around
confidence values along in a several
pets even we each species was clone we
can be confident about is that the
species were looking up the last about
general so that funny or higher are
either the search pieces of your own
companies this is illustrated really
well by the lower right-hand pane when
you have a pseudomonas species which may
be seen among us for a sense but the
confidence is not not higher it's
certainly a new Sumer in the Genesee
tomatoes we're going to table on the
left we can see that certainly the
species and quite abundant in the Sun I
guess this method is not dissimilar to
digital PCR where the number of times
you see the same thing will indicate how
undreds it wasn't the initial sample so
it's not especially surprising that
syndrome this comes out as the most
abundant and we see the range of things
in that some of which we've identified
down to species level some of which we
weren't really sure about that but what
kind of Secrets them finding out but we
thought it'd be really interesting to
take a closer look at one of these
species the only child is my random was
the one which went said was what in
report where I so here's a strain of
klebsiella oxytocin the sequence is
using a pc our free library with
fragments were plotting 20 kilobases
regenerated knots 180 mega bases of data
which is about 30 phone coverage of the
Occitan sativum the sequencing
reassemble using nano corrects because
we've noticed to get it installed in
houston and we obtained a single
counting assembling can be approximately
six mega bases which is the typical size
of an offsetting so Gina
they then performed holding on blast on
TV I to find out when this particular
species arising taxonomy and the shell
of a lifetime pain and this measure its
most closely related to the top part of
the tree the closest match was to a
strain called KO ni h 1 which have been
obtained from a pay metal swell if your
number that I've sample came from city
government it's not always surprising
that is very closely related without
made a bummer politically certainly
against the ki-netic can became an h1
string and you can see on the right that
the turning signal just with a few bits
missing here and there doesn't make a
lot of sense quite in comparative metric
thinking that the assembly is not the
same strange than reference but again 50
was about 5.7 mega bases which is the
full length of the genome so when there
to be end in this presentation and fees
what summarizing a few things that the
main line is a small inexpensive into
portable sequences that supported
sensing device which is capable
producing more needs of sequencing
sequence information in real time this
lenses are particularly relevant to easy
and inexpensive identification and
discovery of microbial species then when
come a couple to announce cover of an
unseasoned also linked in real time it
becomes ideally suited to the real-time
detection and characterization of
microbial species which we think will be
perfect for things like infection
control and Washington County man
senator so what next well oxen and
appointed ambitious company and our
ambitions X don't beyond the confines of
this planet as you might have seen in
the press there are plans to certain
behind up into the International Space
Station in every 2016 which will make it
the first DNA sequencer in space
initially dadliest to see what numbers
it's possible to sequence in space
samples they've been prepared on with
but the longer term plan is to use the
midnight tonight an astronaut health for
instance by limiting monitoring the
intestinal microbial my provider and
ultimately who knows detecting extra
extraterrestrial life then in Italy the
might be wanting like replenishes to
deal with him as the genome do not DNA
the port massager going to handle
whatever strands with her as you might
imagine no try to sequence DNA in zero
gravity prevents if you promote presents
a few problems this is one of the many
places where all transcript cannon
because we've all tracks it'll just be
necessary to the patio so in general
samples in turn the device and vultures
will take care of everything else we in
fact with four more things to consider
in terms of sequence in space as this
one shows and each of these steps needs
to be tested thoroughly before launch
anyway that brings me to the end of
presentation it just reminds me to thank
a few people that feels help out here in
strategy so like to thank all the staff
up to number but particularly the
applications group and it particularly
Cecil whom his team New York for many
experiments at all spartacus in this
presentation and also can hop degrading
slight way to thank out James who made
the idea and also phenomenon by who who
are the metrical people but also likely
to give a special thanks to unite and
the gangster rap by intimate a shindig
layman a Miss Pross see if generating
zone and just quick and also to Chantel
for the gift of the device today and
thanks haven't listened to I'd be very
happy to take any questions thank you
dr. Turner for that informative
presentation before we get started on
all of our questions and our answers I
would like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window we will try to
answer as many questions as we can now
our first question you mentioned that
wimp is quantitative does that mean that
all men I are sequencing is quantitative
and sequencing is quantitative I mean it
depends how you go about setting up a
sequencing reaction I suppose I wouldn't
claim that anything that has a
notification step in it could be
remotely quantitative what I would be
comforted saying no but this is by
fanatics that we need to do proper
detail so you can give a proper a proper
considered opinion especially for
transcriptomics but I think that without
some without the amplification step
become much more closer to having
constitutive system before I can say yes
it is fully quantitative we need to
validate that but I think I don't think
there's any reason
to suspect that it is not contacted
we've not notice any biases GC biases or
80 biases and like I say that's
amplification thus removing another
source of bias thank you we do have
another question our audience member
asks I noticed that in the moonshine
results from wimp reads from cow also
appear but you said the rim workflow was
for bacteria or virus on me does that
mean I can customize the event database
very very very well observed and yes it
does mean that you well okay unless I'm
not going to phrase this very carefully
you it is potentially possible to
customize me when your database it is
not something that we've currently
released as one of the workflows so if
you use the won't work feeling today I'm
able come with with canned workflows for
work and databases for bacteria for
viruses and in the very very near future
funky and as to what you would want to
customize it and it's something that we
do we do debate quite a lot if we know
the species that you want to put in the
database then you might be better off
not using the good work through anyway
it's really it strengthens in looking
for species where you don't know what
you're looking at so for the moment you
can customize it yourself but it is
potentially possible great interesting
another on audience member says this
technology is amazing can anyone get
into the mid iron access program now you
all you have to do is go to go to our
website which is WWE no poor techcom and
register your interest and then we will
be back in touch with you like I said on
the slide is a is an access via a
thousand dollars which means that you
get a million you get a supply of flow
cells and you get some consumables
and if you want more than that then you
can buy them through the shop but yeah
the mineral access program is is open to
anybody great we have another question
you mentioned that you can sequence
modified bases in DNA and showed it for
RNA does that mean all modifications
well you'll appreciate that the number
of modifications that are out there is
vast and in RNA particularly it's a
frightening number of modifications so
for instance in either for every every
every base in RNA you might have say
Frank different methylated variants of
these and it's probably the same for
well I'm not missing the same for DNA
but certainly you have you know a larger
number of modify of methylated seat
beyond just the the 55 meter know what I
can say is that when in the stranding
two when strand passes through banana
pool we see it and it's more the
question is is how we can make sense of
it and so the easiest thing what are
shown in the slide is that if you have a
modified strand and an unmodified
strands and you don't four maybe
Squibbles from knows you can see a
difference I'm not telling that there is
something there that is not matching
with the base called model that we're
using now if we'll me what the most
should have in my position and we then
see that we've got a deviation from that
it implies that there is that there's a
notification there and that particularly
if you're looking at an RNA star novice
engineer topics and get to see what
polymerase looked as well as what they
call it and you can then try and infer
from that the presence of the oil a base
only modified base so we can we can tell
from I start saying pretty much any base
that there is something there that is a
modified version of the base and whether
to get to the point though where we can
put it any strand de novo sequencer and
call which other modifications happen to
be there and that's going to take it a
lot longer because it means that we have
to see you can modify place
in the context that we are going to see
it in the real sample we have to know
what we're looking at well first of all
we have to know what to look for we
don't have to have scans to train our
show the base core with Australian so we
can learn listen to love each one next
one but in time yes we should be on
several counts modified I know 25 bases
without any prior knowledge of prior
assumptions just by putting the DNA are
working on it but that's going to be
some time
this message to justify